medical 304 what is the city and address
of your emergency san diego
terra santa boulevard
unit
repeat that address again
santa boulevard what unit number
okay what's the name of the apartment
there
it's called el dorado greens and it's a
condominium okay what's your phone
number you're calling and tell me
exactly what happened
uh there's smoke coming out from and
under the door of the unit
and um we have a man in there that we
suspect there are mental issues with and
he's not answering the door okay how
many stories is the building
uh this is on the first floor how many
total stories is the building total
storage four stories plus the garage so
five stories five stories okay
all right
okay we're on the way there okay okay
thank you so very much you know if
anybody's home
we don't know he won't answer the door
but there's smoke coming out so we have
no clue all right if there's a fire
alarm to pull go ahead and pull that now
and maybe just uh let the neighbors know
they should evacuate just in case
there's a fire
okay i'll let them okay thank you very
much and who got the gun pointed out
[Applause]
if you have a sort of updated
description on that guy did you it's
probably about in his 50s
black bear uh he was sitting on the
couch so i didn't get a whole
prescription
i'm sorry so he was just on the couch
you guys walked in so i forced the door
open and then uh
he was sitting on the couch in the
living room okay basically just up from
here to
that other clock far away as soon as we
open the door point inspiration right
now where's the system
oh you said you know
he pointed people over he pointed at us
yeah
and then took like a couple steps in and
that's when
this are you sure
stay right
[Applause]
hey get down on the ground
get up
get down
i'm not reloading you're good
come back out watch out cassie
hey drop the button we're not good dude
can you tell them shots fired we don't
have service in here
get outside and tell them bro
we don't want to hurt you we want to
help you out
hey we want to help you bro
hey
get off
you